hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast how small things can have
a big impact on research and breathing
in your Rogan colony presented by Mandy
horn MS and sherry wild MSM be a
certified manager of animal resources
we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth I'm Judy Oracle lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
this presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain your credits please click
on they get your free ce credits button
located in the lower left of your screen
this will take you to a page listing all
of our speakers and presentations please
select the c/e button under the
presentation and follow the instructions
to claim your certificate before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and then time you want during the
presentation just click on the Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen I'll answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that
you'll be viewing the presentation in a
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located in the
lower right and finally if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or you can use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce our speakers Mandy Horan is
supervisor of the North America
veterinary science research and support
department at NV go research models and
services she also serves on the
institutional Animal Care and Use
Committee Mandy received a masters of
science and animal sciences from Purdue
University with a focus on ruined
nutrition and reproduction after which
she began her career in the laboratory
animal industry at MP go RMS her
responsibilities include internal and
external project management model
related technical support and health
monitoring of internal colonies Sherri
wild is the global manager of genetic
quality and reading and envy
RMS she received a bachelor's degree of
Science in biology a Masters of Science
in molecular genetics and an MBA with a
concentration in project management from
Purdue University prior to invivo shared
worked as a research scientist at endo
site where she was among the primary
scientists working on a full-weight
targeted molecular imaging agent used to
identify tumors that express full weight
receptors with expertise in animal
breeding population genetics and
oncology research sherry has served as
invivo are necessary ting and genetics
expert for 14 years please join me in
welcoming Nandi horn I will now turn the
presentation over to her thank you Judy
and I appreciate the opportunity to
speak to you all today on our topic how
small things can have a big impact on
research and breeding in your own at
colony to get started today my portion
is involving questions on do housing and
husbandry matter so today we'll be going
through four topics the first being why
do housing in husbandry matter and what
impacts does do these two topics have on
animal welfare as well as research
outcomes what parameters should be
considered there's many different
parameters and we're going to discuss
some of these more in depth that our
idea is to expose or draw attention to
parameters that could be impactful to
either your breeding or your research
outcomes next we'll look at a paper from
2003 which from a management perspective
how are different parameters more
specifically noise considered by many
types of individuals within an animal
institution and based on these
differences in thought how can they be
best managed and then finally we'll
review two case studies which will
hopefully give you some more food for
thought on some parameters that that may
or may not seem impactful but at the
outcome of your research you will find
that they do impact the in findings
so why do housing and husbandry matter
if we reference the guide the design of
animal facilities combined with
appropriate animal housing and
management are essential contributors to
animal well-being the quality of animal
research and production teaching or
testing programs involving animals and
the health and safety of personnel and
further the guide also considers that
micro environmental conditions can
directly affect physiologic processes
and behavior and may alter disease
susceptibility in addition best
practices also promote adherence to the
3 R's further promoting good animal
welfare we have to be able to assess the
environment and potential variables
prior to experimental initiation and we
want to consider these so that we can
potentially decrease the number of
animals utilize as well as potentially
increase the frequency of reproducible
results we should also document the
husbandry techniques the environmental
conditions and any other parameters for
future reference so that we can allow
ourselves to further refine our studies
so what parameters should be considered
when I started to develop this
presentation I started to put together a
list and recognizing that this is
certainly not an exhaust exhaustive list
there are quite a few parameters to
consider that that can impact not only
your breeding but your research outcomes
and so as we look through this list we
can see not only positive but negative
impacts of the different parameters on
your research for example the literature
supports that changing changes in
bedding type can can certainly impact
the stress of an animal or even growth
changes in diet can affect your gut
microflora and further impact
potentially growth enrichment and
handling are certainly
need to be considered any type of noise
vibration or all factory stimuli those
have all been reported to impact
breeding sometimes positively sometimes
negatively within your within your
research institution and as we look
through some of these others lighting
and temperature as well as humidity
those those can impact and you may not
recognize that you're impacting your
research if you're not aware certainly
caging and cage density as we increase
or decrease those parameters
specifically cage density you can you
can create stress to that environment
and therefore alter the the research
outcome obviously the experimental
variables are going to impact your
research but being aware of all of those
and potential interactions is important
and then pain pain and distress or
restraint as well as transportation can
cause some animal welfare concerns or
other potential potential impacts to
stress and so really just you know the
point i'd like to make with this slide
is that nothing should be left out and
as we're developing our studies as we're
developing our breeding programs within
our institutions we should consider all
of these parameters and really you know
not not leave any stone unturned as we
develop our programs so in 2003 Jane and
Baldwin said set aside and developed a
pilot study focusing on laboratory
animal stress within their housing
environment and if if the investigators
were aware that that stress can impact
or effect their physiological data so
this was a pilot study to determine the
prevalence of noise in the facility and
whether the researchers were aware that
noise can affect animal physiology this
group sent a survey to 49 scientists
involved in animal research in the u.s.
their response rate was fifty-nine
percent and they found that their survey
indicated two trends either that the
recommendation
for animal housing and the research
institutions institutions was largely
ignored as well as a dichotomy existing
regarding noise and what is observed
versus what is acceptable from that
point they hypothesize the following
that the investigators would fall within
three different constructs the first
being that are the first to being that
either there was awareness that
environmental factors affected animal
physiology as well as awareness of
environmental conditions within their
own facilities and then the third being
the perception of an existence of a
mind-body interaction in an animal so
they further took the first two
constructs and broke those down into
four separate areas and they they termed
those as unaware and unaware group and
aware or Ana where / aware group and
unaware / aware group or in a where
group and so as they further looked at
these within the unaware group this
group does not know that the environment
can affect an animal's physiology and
this group really just lacks an
understanding of stress physiology so
this these types of people within your
institution maybe you know a delivery
person of a lab supply you know they're
just not aware that that environment
impacts animal physiology the second
group is aware that the environment can
affect an animal's physiology but
they're unaware of the conditions in
their own animal facility this an
example of a person in this group might
be a principal investigator and so
they're certainly well versed in in the
physiology aspect but they're not
involved in the day-to-day within the
vivarium and so they just don't have a
good grasp of the conditions in their
own facility the third group the unaware
aware group is unaware that the
environment can affect an animal's
physiology
they do know the conditions in their own
facility and so this might be a
technician or an animal facility
personnel that spends lots of time in
the facility that they're just they just
lack the awareness of the literature or
the full understanding of how noise can
impact animal physiology and then the
fourth group is the aware group and this
group is aware that the environment can
affect the physiology and of their
facilities condition so this might be
your veterinarian or a vivarium manager
within the site and so the conclusion
that they came to is there there's a
lack of awareness between investigators
and personnel maintaining and inspecting
animal facilities regarding noise and
you have to really be able to share
knowledge throughout the facility so
that you can adhere to the 3 R's and and
actually produce good research with
reproducible data from a management
perspective then looking at that at that
paper we have to be aware that changes
to housing and husbandry can affect or
can impact research outcomes we have to
be involved with our investigators what
type of research is being conducted and
how it can be in half how it could be
impacted and then recognize that nothing
is out of the question we have to
consider every detail potentially
impactful so now I'd like to go through
a few scenarios just to give you made me
a better understanding of some things
that we may have experienced and how we
were able to find that something that we
didn't consider either from a research
technician side or from a technical
perspective was impactful and so the
first example involved a growth
bodyweight glucose and hba1c study and
zucker rats this was a 12-week study
where the animals were monitored on a
weekly basis for the various parameters
in order to gather more phenotypic data
on the model
and so the research technician reported
that non fasted blood glucose values
were significantly greater during week
seven compared to the other weeks which
we know is a typical of the model
phenotype the sucker model is not a
diabetic model and therefore should have
a more normal non facit blood glucose so
the results were really intriguing to us
and so we began to investigate and
reviewed various parameters including
the timing of the glucose monitoring and
sharing consistency week to week looking
at light changes within the animal room
to see if there were any impacts or
changes to that were there changes to
the personnel you know did we have a
technician come in and perform the cage
changes in those animals that maybe
isn't the normal technician did we have
a technician on vacation and so we had
someone else come in we ensured that the
bedding and the diet hadn't changed we
were still feeding the standard diet
still using the standard bedding for
that model and then also reviewed the
cage cleaning schedule within that room
and so upon reviewing all of this data
we realized that the cages were cleaned
with in this facility within this room
prior to blood glucose measurements and
the reason was that the animal
technician wanted to ensure that the
research technician had the best
possible environment to perform the the
part of her study which was taking the
blood for measuring blood glucose and
and just ensuring that it the room was
clean so certainly not any malicious
intention the animal technician just
like I said wanted to ensure that that
the research technician had the best
possible environment available if we if
we consider the the paper that I
referenced you know the animal
technician just wasn't aware of the
impact that her work had on the outcome
of the study and so what we found was
that
when the research technician discussed
the importance of not performing a cage
cleaning prior to the measurement of
blood glucose and alluded to the fact
that that can cause stress which can
lead to a higher blood glucose value
when when we were allowed to or when we
helped explain that then the technician
better understood and made sure that on
her end she did everything possible to
not negatively impact the study as
another example we found that we had a
customer that was receiving time ated
sprague-dawley rats at an early
gestation for a number of years from the
same and viggo facility and they called
us and they were reporting that within
some recent orders they had findings of
non pregnant rats either with resorption
they were seeing increased
cannibalization and animals that were
delivering or they were seeing death in
the dams and or the pups and so they
were really concerned with what what
might be occurring on our end and
looking to looking to us to help them
troubleshoot and work through those
issues so we you know we did some
investigating on our end ensuring that
there were changes to housing and
husbandry diet things like that and the
customer also investigated at their
institution they involve their
veterinary staff they were looking at
bedding and diet as well as cage type
they were considering animal technicians
and any potential differences in animal
technicians they were looking at the
overall vivarium were there any changes
there any construction any lighting
changes things like that as well as
external environmental changes which as
as the this person later found out there
was a new construction project nearby
right next door actually to their
facility and so what they found was that
the construction project next to their
vivarium involved a large amount of
noise and
shin and not only were they reporting
issues with the time gain time to mated
animals they were receiving from us but
also their internal colonies leading to
losses at their institution and so for
this one unfortunately the construction
next door couldn't be stopped however
they did have increased awareness and
they did have some further discussions
with this outside company and you know
just on the impact of that construction
project to their animal vivarium as a
third example we have an immunodeficient
animal model which previously exhibited
young pup death we performed an
extensive root cause and found that the
addition of a specific enrichment type
reduce the pup death within this colony
so we had an issue found found the cause
and and everything seemed to be going
fine however we had a problem then with
this model when the facility began to
report an increased incidence of young
pup death again and so we we initiated a
second root cause investigating multiple
factors including humidity within the
flexible film isolator as well as the
room lighting ensuring that the lighting
cycles were 12 on 12 off where the
isolator was located you know was it in
a quiet place was it loud where the
animals being maintained on the correct
diet as well as the correct bedding had
the enrichment change was there a vendor
change with the enrichment a change to
the enrichment type similar to our first
example was there a change in the animal
technician or maybe a technician out on
vacation and and somebody was new and as
well as the genetic testing results from
this model was there was there something
amiss with that what we found out from
this was that the technician was a new
technician overseeing the colony and she
failed to utilize the crinkle paper in
Richmond and the breed
cages over two-week period that time
period was enough that that resulted in
an increase in pot death with the animal
model and so is a resolution we again
added the enrichment back to the
breeding cages and then had some
retraining with this new model as far as
the importance of the enrichment and how
that really impacted the management and
the success of the model and as a final
example this one was a research study
involving a compound administered
through the water and there was reported
to be acute death in the study animals
however they also reported or noted an
increase in water consumption so again
similar to the other investigations
diets temperature humidity water bottle
contents etc were all all investigated
and evaluated within the within the
study and what they concluded was that
there was an increased temperature in
the animal room which resulted in
increased water consumption and because
the compound was being dosed through the
water they were effectively overdosing
the animals which in the case of this
compound resulted in animal death and so
the resolution was that operations
adjusted the temperature to the
appropriate range and then the research
technicians closely monitored the room
temperature and water consumption during
their studies so in conclusion for this
piece of the presentation I hope you
recognize that communication is key
between all individuals within your
vivarium from your your supporting staff
your animal technicians your vivarium
managers veterinarians principal
investigators you know your your summer
help that comes in it's very important
to have good communication and you have
to be knowledgeable about practices and
procedures in your institution as well
as any potential impact on either animal
well-being or
study out study outcome and then finally
animal technicians veterinary staff
managers and investigators should work
closely especially if there are any
changes to any of these procedures you
know if a bedding type has changed let's
say doodle cost savings we need to make
sure you know as an as a person in
operations that we're notifying the p.i
so that they can document that and then
if that if they would later report a
change to you know their research
outcome they might or they could
attribute that to the change in bedding
and so just ensuring that that any
change is reported and recorded and
shared with you know with everyone and
within the institution and so with that
I will turn it over to my colleague
Cherie to go over the next part hello
everybody thank you for joining today I
would like to talk about genetic
background as a research variable and so
as an overview what I'd like to start
with today is just some common breeding
schemes colony management and genetics
and then we'll talk about genetic
background and how it can affect gene
expression so the first thing I wanted
to talk about was what genetic
background does your model have I think
a lot of people order animals they get
these animals into their facilities and
they don't often think about the genetic
background and that it can change over
time so we're going to talk about some
con breeding schemes I'm going to really
focus on the most common ones which
include inbreds out Reds hybrids and
then mixed models for inbred strains
those are typically animals that have
been submitted at least 20 generations
they are considered genetically
identical so they are isogenic many
inbred strains have been bred for a
particular trait they reduce research
variability so there's a pro with the
inbred strain and they're on a stable
genetic background
so it's much harder for the genetic
background to change over time but they
are less vigorous they don't produce as
well they usually have a smaller
littered average this is just an example
of one inbred strain which is the c57
black six mouse we also have out red
stocks so when you're dealing with an
out bud model I think a lot of people
tend to want to refer to those as
outbred strains but actually we would
refer to those as a stock and they
should be different from animal to
animal genetically we want to maintain
those in a colony of at least 25
unrelated pair actually here at in Vigo
we would we would actually keep those in
a colony size of no less than 50 but
typically as long as the the pairs are
unrelated you can go down to 25 pair and
they have hybrid vigor so they're very
healthy animals they have required
literate averages and they could
possibly translate better to human
studies there's a little bit of argument
on that one but a lot of researchers
believe that they translate better but
on the downside they can increase
variability in between replications of
your study and the genetic background is
more unstable so it's much easier to
affect the genetic background through
selection pressure or some things the
technician might be doing so that's a
downside and here's just another example
this is an out bread rat it's a
sprague-dawley so we have another kind
of model we call f1 hybrids these result
from crossing mice of two different
inbred strains they're heterozygous at
all low sigh so that makes them geminate
genetically and fina typically uniform
so that's a pro and they do have hybrid
vigor as well but unfortunately that
uniformity is only present in the f1
generation if you go beyond the f1 then
you start to get the genes to segregate
and you get different animals in the
same litter genetically and this is just
an example of a cba f1 hybrid mouse and
finally we have mixed models there's no
real specific breathing scheme there
no specific colony size they're not
really in bread but they're not really
out bread and we often see these with
genetically modified models typically
when you modify my model model
genetically you're going to use a c57
black 6 and there's 129 involved as well
and so a lot of times we'll see models
that are a mix of these two strains
together and people don't necessarily
maintain a specific colony size they
just breathe the animals and you use the
animals for their research without
really thinking about the genetic
background so there's some other kinds
of models that you may have come in
contact with some are called congenic
mortals I won't go into the specific
details of all of these but there's also
transgenics we have targeted mutant
models and then spontaneous mutant
models so all of these models or models
that have the gene or gene moved around
perhaps it's a gene from a human onto a
mouse or perhaps it's a particular gene
or mutation on one mouse train that's
been moved to another so it these are
all specialized type of models and I
wanted to say a word about nomenclature
it's really important to follow proper
rules for nomenclature a lot of people
are tempted to abbreviate so they went
to four c57 black six for example they
might want to write c57 on the cage card
but it's really important to write out
the whole nomenclature because it can
tell you a lot about the model and this
is just an example c57 black six if you
see there's a forward slash in the
nomenclature whenever you see a forward
slash in your nomenclature you know
you're dealing with an inbred model so
what's nice about this is you don't
really have to understand everything
it's sort of like I called the Rosetta
Stone of a AB nomenclature if you know
the slashes and the dashes and the dots
then you can usually tell what kind of
model you're working with here's another
example where you see a colon in the
nomenclature and the colon means that
it's an out bread so as soon as you see
that you know you're immediately dealing
with an out red model here is a model
that has a slow
so immediately you know seeing the slash
it's an inbred model but you also see a
dot in the nomenclature when you see a
dot that means it's a congenic so a
particular mutation has been moved from
one type of model to another here is a
model where you see you see a something
in parentheses which is typically this
would be a transgenic model and you'll
see TG and then you'll see a bunch of
letters and and at information at the
end and that's that what that means is
that it's an inbred because you see the
slash and it's a transgenic model and
this one in particular is on an f vb
background and then here's another
example where you see in superscripted
you'll see a TM and what that means is
it's a targeted mutant or a knockout so
if you know all those little tricks and
hints it can tell you this one in
particular is on a c57 black 6 so it's
an inbred again there's a slash it's a
knockout and actually at the end it says
it's on generation 5 so you can look up
all the guidelines for nomenclature at
this particular website this is the
committee that makes the rules on how to
do nomenclature and I would encourage
everybody to familiarize yourself with
nomenclature because it really can tell
you a lot about the model you're working
with so now that you know what you have
you have to keep it that way and genetic
change is always working against us
there are two ways that major ways that
you can have genetic change happen in
your colony one is through genetic
contamination and one is through genetic
drift genetic contamination is caused
when you have an accidental miss mating
between two unrelated models it can be
identified through coat color changes
typically but you can also easily miss
it and when you miss it it's usually
because you have animals of the same
coat color but a different strain in the
same room poor cage labeling or
record-keeping you don't have a routine
genetic monitoring program to catch a
contamination if it did occur and when
you have out breads
stocks it can be very difficult to
assess it's sort of like a needle in a
haystack to find the contamination it
can lead to inaccurate research data and
you can use you can really lose years of
research time data and money especially
if you have a model that is two
different colors they've contaminated
each other and you you think your
compound under you think your research
is really working great but it could be
a function of the genetic change in the
animal instead of whatever research that
you're doing so to prevent genetic
contamination you really need to know
what you're starting with so you don't
you are able to test against something
until you actually know what your
baseline is make sure you keep your coat
color separate it's very important and
be sensitive to phenotypic changes so if
you see something in the animals that
seems different in their behavior or
anything that could be phenotypic you
should report that you should keep good
records you should have a genetic
testing program periodically you should
always test your animals to make sure
they are the genetic background that
they should be and then genetic drift is
another way that you can get change in
your colony this is due to spontaneous
mutations so genetic drift isn't
something that we can stop it's a
natural process but there are things you
can do to kind of minimize it or to slow
it down so spontaneous mutations occur
randomly throughout the genome and they
typically it typically occur in
non-coding DNA but it can result in a
phenotypic change occasionally because
sometimes it does occur in coding DNA
this is caused often by selection
pressure so selection pressure is
something that can happen for example
when a technician is working with
animals and they decide that they they
want to pick an animal that's giving all
female litters or more females in the
litter because that's what they're
studying or they're selecting animals
that have larger litters they might
select animals that look bigger or
healthier and all of that can cause
pressure and while you are selecting for
a trait you want you could be selecting
against a trait that you want or you
could be introduced
sing a trait that you don't want so that
selection pressure it can again a lead
to the elimination of a desired trait or
an introduction of a non desirable trait
and then the last part is bottlenecks
this is really for out breads that's
when you breed closely related animals
in an outbreak colony and you lose
alleles or you cause large changes in
the frequency in which those alleles
happen and this is just a nice example
of how bottlenecks work so so in this
example you could think of the first
bottle is being a colony of animals and
some of them carry the white jean and
some carry the red gene and both of
those are important in somebody's study
and if you decide to take the colony and
read arrive it or start a new colony and
you only select a handful of animals to
do that in the end your population that
you're starting with and the third
figure here is going to have far more
red than white and in the end you may
end up bringing the white out completely
so this is what genetic bottlenecking is
and what you have to do when you start a
new population or you're maintaining an
out read to keep that change from
happening you need to maintain an
appropriate size a colony size and that
would be 25 unrelated pair or more so to
minimize genetic change you need to
maintain the appropriate number of
animals in your colony avoid selection
pressure you need to follow a specific
breeding protocol have excellent record
keeping monitor your colonies and just
know what you you know know what you're
starting with and know what you want to
shoot for in the end so the last part of
this talk I really just wanted to do a
few case studies on how genetic
background matters I think I've run into
some people that have thought that you
know all that matters is the mutation so
it doesn't matter what genetic
background it on the animal is that
whatever mutation it has will cause the
phenotype that's not always the case for
example we have the LEP rdb model or the
diabetic mouse and it is a model of type
1 diabetes it's a spot
kenya's single nucleotide mutation in
the lepr gene and what it causes is OB
obesity and the early onset of juvenile
hyper gleich hyperglycemia it you lose
me up there's a massive loss of beta
cells and islet atrophy within two
months after puberty and this is on the
c57 black Kahless inbred strain it
causes obesity and transient diabetes on
the black six inbred strain so what you
can see is you have a much different
phenotype on a Kahless background then
you do on a black six background so it's
much more it's much more severe on a
Kahless than it is on a black six the
skin model is another good example this
is severe combined immunodeficiency and
on an odd genetic background it lacks T
cells B cells severe NK cell impairment
there's no compliment activity there's
impaired macrophage development and
impaired antigen presenting cell
function on a bob c background it only
lacks t-cells and b-cells but all the
other cells work so that's there's a
very big difference and I know skids one
of those where I think sometimes people
think you know it's such a severe
mutation it doesn't matter what
background is on but it definitely
matters and your animal is going to be
more immuno compromised on an odd
background and on a bouncy background
they may be surprised at the result the
last example is um what I won't you know
spill it all the letters here but this
is a g93a transgenic mouse model and it
contains several mutant human sonic 1
genes and it's used in the study of ALS
you get severe progressive
neurodegeneration of the motor system
when you use sjl and c3h inbred mouse
models but the phenotype is much milder
if you were to use a black 6 a black 10
or about c model so there's a big
difference there in the phenotype
also if it's on a mixed background the
phenotype is much milder so in summary
you should know the genetic background
of the model that you're working with
minimize genetic change in your colony
once you know what you have know what
you know what you're shooting for so you
need to minimize genet you need a
midnight minimize genetic drift you need
to not have genetic contamination if at
all possible but if you do you need a
way to be able to detect that remember
that genetic background can be a very
large research fear variable and that's
the end of the talk thank you thank you
both for your informative presentations
it's time for Q&A if you have a question
you'd like to ask Mandy horn or sherry
wild please do so now just click on the
Queen Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
question into the box it appears on your
screen and click the send button will
answer as many questions as we have time
for let's get started our first question
is do you have or know of a checklist to
help in an investigation when problems
are found as in the pregnancy resorption
example so that's a really good question
we don't have a checklist per se you
know within our department at NV go we
provide technical support and so
something that we do is you know like I
alluded to with this presentation was we
have a list of items that will go
through so you know we'll look at you
know we'll start with husband durian and
changes to animal technicians will look
at the animal model maybe even the
genetics or the consistency of the
animals that are coming out will
consider the bedding in the diet you
know we'll look at temperature and
humidity you know differences to cage
density or construction or noise so you
know the the one slide you know that
listed all the different parameters
that's that's kind of a good checklist
I'd say I'm worried a good place to
start and really you know I think as you
start to investigate these things you
know you'll start to go through and one
item may lead to another and and so you
may you know start looking at the animal
technician and then recognize that the
betting changed and then recognize that
the cage density changed and you may
find a lot of different parameter
changes as you go through it how do you
deal when the control key deal when the
control group has the same background
but is not related to the GM strain the
control group came from somewhere else
um you know is that I'm sorry it won't
work okay sorry I think that's a that's
actually a really good question um it's
difficult because doing genetic
monitoring to check your control strain
the technology is there there are panels
that you can use and I would suggest you
can use panels that are a little bit
deeper that are going to give you a
little bit more resolution to check and
and you can compare the backgrounds of
your your your transgenic strain to your
control strain but it doesn't really
give you the whole picture it can tell
you if there are large changes in
between the two models but you would
have to sequence the entire genome of
both animals to tell if there are a
hundred percent the same so my advice to
people is always to try to get a control
that comes from the same place as the
background of the other model but you
can also use I mean if you talk about
vendors for example you can also use
them as a resource because we have a lot
of information about the genetic
background of the different substrains
so for example if you have a transgenic
model that was on a you know a black 6j
model from jackson and you want to know
if you can use an n' as your control
that's a that's
thing that we could give you information
on and tell you what sort of things to
expect what sort of genetic differences
there are but there's not really a
hundred percent great answer for that
one it is it is one that you struggle
with but I definitely think you should
run at least some of the larger panels
on some of those we have panels that are
1,500 markers that are routinely run but
at least give you some idea that you're
in the ballpark with your control strain
the next person says this is a question
more about environment than genetics is
there any data or inference that the
various methods of rodent ID ear tags
punches chips tattoos might impact the
animal and study data that's a good
question I'm not aware of any specifics
I would think that there could be some
just looking at different levels of
stress that a different you know that a
different identification method might
have you know maybe you know one would
create more acute stress than another
one may lead to more chronic stress as
the animals healing and so certainly an
acclimation period around the ID you
know the identification time period
might might be recommended but that's
you know unfortunately that's not
something I'm aware of in the literature
but I think it's an excellent question
and something to consider you know as
part of your study if there are no more
questions that would like to once again
thank Mandy horn and sherry wild for
their presentations do you have any
final comments to share with us today no
they thank you again for the opportunity
and and you know if there are questions
afterwards you know we'll certainly be
able to take those
thank you as a reminder this
presentation has been approved for
continuing educational credits if you
want to obtain the credits please click
on the get your free secrets button
located in the lower left of your screen
this will take you to a page listing all
of our speakers and presentations please
select the c/e button under the
presentation and follow the instructions
to claim your certificate before I go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through august 3rd 2016 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please show that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon bye